字幕: Haruko NAGAI
校正: Natsuhiko Mizutani
（バンバラ語）こんにちは
これ バンバラ語です
私はマリ共和国 バマコで生まれ
19歳までバマコで生活しました
その後 国費留学生として中国に渡り
６年間ほど中国で生活しました
日本には91年に来て
今は32年間が経とうとしています
ちなみに私は2002年に日本国籍を取得し
国籍上 実は日本人歴の方が
マリ人歴より長いんですよね
にもかかわらず 私がこの国際会館の外で
「俺も日本人やで！」って叫んでも
お前何言うとんねんと
言われそうな気がします
それはですね やっぱり
国籍とアイデンティティと
また人種を重ねて考える
いわゆる そういうのが
単一であると考える日本人が
多いからだというふうに思います
私が来た90年には
ちょうどバブルの崩壊の頃だったんで
個人も企業も実は自信にあふれて
国外に目を向けた日本人も
非常に多かったと思います
それから30年が経ちました
何が変わったんでしょうか
例えば 私が住んでいるこの京都では
少子化 高齢化
皆さんもご存じのように
空き家が次第に増え
さらにその一部が
マンションに建て替わってきた
また 在住外国人も増えて
皆さんも珍しくないと思いますが
祇園祭とか地域の祭り等々で
外国人の姿が目立ちます
そのような京都というのは
どういうふうに今後なっていくか
京都は文化のシーンを大切にしつつも
実は外からの変化というのは
対応してきた場所だというふうに
私は信じております
私はこの京都では新しい共創社会のモデルが
実現できるかなというふうに信じております
今日の話は
それを中心にしていきたいと思います
［グローバル化の定義］
まずグローバル化の定義をしたいと思います
グローバル化というのは
皆さんもご存じのように
国際化とはまず違って
一つはですね ヒト モノ カネ 情報が
国境を越えて自由に行き来する
一番大事なのが
物事の価値というのは
一国の判断でできないというのが重要です
これまで我々が考えてきたのが国際化で
国際化というのは
一つの国の中で考えられたもので
その国と他の国の関係
あるいは一国と複数の国の関係
これは20世紀で終わったと思います
グローバル化というのは
国の概念を超えて
個人または集団が行き来するということと
またその国の政策では
それがルールが決められないということが
重要であります
このグローバル化にはまたもう一つ大事なのが
［ダイバーシティ］
ダイバーシティ
つまり多様性であります
［多様性（当たり前の違い）］
多様性というのは
人種 性別 性的指向 社会的経済的背景
および個人間の違いがある
民族も含めて
この違いを認識するだけです
実は私たちが考えていくときに
この個人間の当たり前が違うということは
あまり意識しようとしない
受け入れないっていうことが多いですね
「我々は一緒だよ」という同調のもとで
やってきたわけです
私も学長を経験した者として
グローバル化
あるいは多様性の政策を打ち出した時に
基本的には当然ながら
マジョリティーを優遇する政策というのは
あるんですが
ただ それを超えたところで
マジョリティーの意識改革が重要だ
というふうに私は思いました
つまり 同調的に自分がマジョリティー
実は特徴がある
他の人と違うのにそれは言えない
それを打ち出せない
我慢してるというような人たちが多いと
マイノリティーを実は決めるのもそういう
マジョリティーのことじゃないかなと
いう風に思います
もう一つはですね この多文化主義です
多文化主義というのは
多様性と違う背景というと
多文化主義は複数の文化的背景が
同じような社会の中で
存在することであります
個人間の違いと同時に
この多文化主義を受け入れる社会を
作っていくことが
非常に重要だというふうに思います
私は91年に来て
最初は京都大学という大学で勉強しました
私は日本に来て一番やっぱり違いを感じたのが
まず人とのコミュニケーションのことであります
皆さんご存じのように
日本人同士でも会う時に
どっちかというとタメ（ため口）を使うのかどうするのか
とにかくカテゴリー化しようとするんですよね
「小さい頃どんなテレビを見たのか」
「いや ちょっとお前何年生まれか」
っていうのは
直接言わずに言うんですよね
この「同い（おない）」という文化と
もう一つはですね
私が何か行動すると
「あいつＡ型ちゃうか？」
（笑）
「いや あの雑なやり方ってＢ型やろ」
「いやー あの頑固さって午年かな」
とにかくカテゴリー化した上でしか
私と付き合わない
こういうことに
すごい私は苦しんでいたんですね
もう一つは やっぱり日本で一番大変だったのが
外国人として
下宿を借りるとか
私はムスリムなので
食事制限をどう対応するかとか
当時私が来たときに
留学生を受け入れる10万人計画
今は最近30万人計画なんですが
この中で
学校は 受け入れ機関は用意できてるんですが
日本人が準備できていない
いわゆる外国人を受け入れる社会の準備が
実は進んでいなかったんですね
これが非常に私は大きく問題として感じました
そこで私は仲間と一緒に
「トビウオ」という組織を作って
やってくる外国人はお客さんではないので
彼らがどうやって日本で生活するかという
リテラシー
あるいはそういうようなマナーとか
いろいろな形で外国人と日本人の
関係をつくるような場を設けてきました
その中で 実は私は
そこで大変大事だったのが
他者と出会うことによって自分を再発見する
［他者と出会う自分を再発見］
これは非常に重要です
異文化と接することっていうのは
自分の文化を理解する機会でもある
自分の文化をまた見つめ直す
自分の当たり前が通じない瞬間に
他の当たり前が
どうなっているのかということを
見るところであります
もう一つ大事なのが
これは日本でもですね ことわざにある
「郷に入れば郷に従え」というんですが
でもみんな郷になったら
大変だなっていう風に私は思います
つまり 私は郷にならず
［同化せずに居場所開拓］
自分のアイデンティティを保持しつつ
この日本社会の
一員になっていくというのが重要で
いわゆる同化せずに居場所を求める
ということが
私は重要だったと思います
私はそれを基にですね
この日本で生活してきました
もうひとつはですね
皆さんもご存知のように
これは日本だけではなくて
結局世界いろんなところで
［ステレオタイプと異文化→］
「よそものコンプレックス」
というような言葉があります
いわゆるよそ者が来て
［フレーム化による排除］
知らないから排除するっていう
［よそものコンプレックス］
これはもう歴史的にはあるんです
そういう意味で
日本でも私たちが来るときに
一番大きいのがですね
外国人というフレームが作られるんです
これをフレーム化っていうんですけど
この「ガイジン」というフレームで
我々を見てしまうようなことが多いです
個人として見ず
「マス」として
あいつらは中国人とか
何々人とか
マリ人とか
私も来た時によくありました
マリ出身と言った瞬間に
「嬉しいです」
「どうしたんですか？」
「動物大好きです」
これどう対応したらいいか分からへんね
（笑）
そういうことでいっぱいありました
だから ある意味で非常にこう
日本社会の中でとにかく
皆さんが持っている先入観でもって
相手を見てしまうという
これが非常にステレオタイプ化の現象です
この先入観というのは
時々排除 いわゆる
スティグマということに繋がってしまいます
私が住んでいる京都では
よくあることなんですけど
京都のお婆さんの喋る時によくあるんですけど
「お婆さんどこそこはどこですか？」
って日本語で聞いた瞬間に
お婆さんは「英語分からへん」って
おっしゃるんですよね
「いや お婆さん 日本語ですよ」
って言っても
私が日本語でしゃべっても
お婆さんの耳に辿り着くまでに
どうも英語になるらしいんですよね
これがもうステレオタイプ化の
もう一番基本です
それを避けていきましょうということです
もしかしたら
世界で コミュニケーションの面で
日本は様々な問題があるというふうに
言われております
どういうことかというと
実はですね エドワード・ホールという
文化人類学者が言ったのは
直接的な言葉ではなく
文脈 暗黙知を重視しながら
［コミュニケーション論 →］
コミュニケーションを取るっていう文化は
ハイコンテクストという風に言います
［ハイコンテクスト］
それに対して
この言葉を大切にして言葉通りに沿って
論理性を重視しながら
コミュニケーションをとるというのは ローコンテクスト
［ローコンテクスト］
このハイコンテクストという文化は
空気を読む文化というふうに言われております
日本では空気を読むということは
実はコミュニケーションの基本になっていて
それが世界では一番
ある意味で最たるハイコンテクストの文化です
それが空気です
時々我々が空気を読むこと自体は
全部悪いというわけではないんですが
ただ空気が我々を不自由にすることがあります
空気を読みすぎる
私も学生たちとのコミュニケーションの中で
よく出てくる話で
意見言わないのが美徳とか
人に合わせるのがトラブル少ないとか
実は一番トラブルが多い時なんですよね
こういうことを思って私も経験してきて
これからのコミュニケーションを
どうしていくかということは
非常に重要だというふうに私は思っています
これから共創社会の実現
［共創社会の実現 →］
ある意味で同化をせずに
［同化でなく、共存による］
どうやって社会が共存していくかということが
非常に私は重要だと思います
その意味で
私たちがお互いのことを
受け入れながら成長していく
とにかく さっき話したように
このアイデンティティをどう重視するのか
お互いのアイデンティティというのは
どういうふうに
認め合っていくかっていうことが
私はこれから重要だというふうに
思っております
その中で
私たちが実は今 直面しているのは
［軸がなくなったアイデンティティ］
アイデンティティクライシスであります
［アイデンティティクライシス］
我々の軸というアイデンティティが
今 いろんな形で変わってきている
［絶対的なものではない］
というのは 今の我々の現実では
一つの文化 社会 あるいは現実の中で
生きるということは
もはやグローバル化によって
それはもう不可能になってきています
私たちは日常生活の中で
いろんなものが私たちの周りにあって
そういうようなものを合わせて
どう自分のアイデンティティを
きちんと保持していくかというところですね
実はこれは日本も例外ではありません
このアイデンティティというのは
教育と伝統によって
これまで引き継がれてきたということだけで
実はきちんとそれを
個人が感じるというところまで
いってないんじゃないかというふうに
私は思っています
つまり どういうことかというと
私たちが自分の足元の文化というのは
しっかり見つめ
いわゆる自分の
アイデンティティというのを
大事にするというのは
自分の軸を持つということでもあるし
自分の足元の文化を理解して
それを受け入れて 見定めた上で
異文化を受け入れていく
実は自分を受け入れる人というのは
他人も受け入れるはずなんです
リチャード・セネットが言ったのが
実は我々は
自信のなさの裏返しが
排他的だというふうに言っています
多くの日本の方々が 今 自信を失ってます
この自信を取り戻すことが
これからの共生社会をつくることに
重要だというふうに私は思っています
これを私は CO-CREATIONというふうに言います
［CO-CREATION／共創社会の実現］
我々がお互いにお互いのことを認め
お互いを尊重しあって
さらに自分が自信を持って
他者とコミュニケーションすることが
重要だというふうに私は思っています
それを可能にするには
ソクラテスがかつて言っていた
ダイアログという方法があります
それは我々が対話姿勢であるということです
そのためにこの３つの質問が重要ですね
［ダイアログ］
私は何者なのか
[WHO AM I]
あなたは何者なのか
[WHO YOU ARE]
我々が何者なのかということです
[WHO WE ARE]
自分を知る
他者に興味を持つというのは
実は自分自身が自分のことで
気になっていることを
他の人を通して
理解することあるんですよね
よく心理学者でも言ってるんですが
これは他人を鏡に使って
自分を見つめ直していくということが
非常に重要であろうというふうに
言われております
私はこのことをしていくっていうのは
実は一番重要なのが
コモンズの精神であります
コモンズの精神というのは
当事者同士が話し合って
共有財産である社会というのを
大切につくっていくことが
大事だと思います
この共創社会というのは
我々にとってコモンズである
その精神が大事であります
それを考えるのに
私はこのアフリカのことわざを
皆さんに贈りたいと思います
If you want to go fast, go alone
［アフリカのことわざ］
If you want to go far, go together.
早く行きたければ一人で進め
遠くまで行きたければ みんなで進め
これを心に留めつつですね
最後に これからの共創社会の実現には
［これからの共創社会の実現→］
ダイアログという手法を通して
［ダイアログ→］
このコミュニケーション
［コミュニティーとコモンズ］
コモンズという
ソーシャルデザインの方法を使って
新しい共創社会を
つくっていただければと思います
私の話は以上としますが
これが実現できれば
私は夢を見る社会ができるかなというふうに
思っています
京都がその出発点になれば
というふうに思っております
ありがとうございました
（バンバラ語）ありがとう
（拍手）